Everybody feels lonely from time to time when we have no one to sit next to at
lunch when we moved to new city or when nobody has time for us and the weekend.
But over the last few decades,
this occasional feeding has become chronic familiar ones.
In the UK,
60% of 18 to 34 year olds say they often feel lonely in the u s 46% of the
entire population feel lonely regularly.
We are living in the most connected time in human history and yet an
unprecedented number of us and feel isolated,
being lonely and being alone.
I'm not the same thing.
You can be filled with blessed by herself and hate every second surrounded by
France.
Loneliness is a purely subjective individual experience.
If you feel lonely,
you are lonely.
A common stereotype is that loneliness only happens to people who don't know how
to talk to people or how to behave around others,
but population based studies have shown that social skills make practically no
difference for adults when it comes to social connections,
loneliness can affect everybody.
Money,
fame,
power,
beauty,
social skills,
a great personality.
Nothing can protect you against loneliness because it's part of your biology.
Loneliness is a bodily function like hunger.
Hunger makes you pay attention to your physical needs.
Learners makes you pay attention to your social needs.
Your body cares about your social needs because millions of years ago,
it was a great indicator of how likely you are to survive natural selection,
rewarded our ancestors for collaboration and for forming connections with each
other.
Our brains grew and became more and more fine tuned to recognize what others
thought and felt and to form and sustain social bonds.
Being social became part of our biology.
You were born into groups of 50 to 150 people,
which you usually stayed with for the rest of your life.
Getting enough calories,
staying safe and warm or caring for offspring was practically impossible.
Alone.
Being together meant survival.
Being alone meant death,
so it was crucial,
but you got along with others for your ancestors.
The most dangerous threat to survival was not being eaten by a lion,
but not getting the social vibe of your group and being excluded to avoid that
your body came up with social pain.
Hainer vest kind is an evolutionary adaptation to rejection,
a sort of early warning system to make sure you stop behavior that would isolate
you,
your ancestors who experienced as more painful.
We're more likely to change their behavior when they got rejected and thus state
and the tribe,
while those who did not got kicked out and most likely died.
That's why rejections hurt and even more so why luminous is so painful.
These mechanisms for keeping US connected worked great for most of our history
until humans began building a new world for themselves.
The loneliness epidemic we see today.
Radio knee started in the late renaissance.
Western culture began to focus on the individual.
Intellectuals moved away from the collectivism of the Middle Ages while the
young Protestant theology stress to individual responsibility.
This trend accelerated during the industrial revolution.
People left there,
but it is and fields to enter factories.
Communities that had existed for hundreds of years began to dissolve.
Well,
cities grew as our world rapidly became modern.
This trend sped up more and more.
Today we move vast distances for new jobs,
love and education and leave our social net behind.
We meet fewer people in person and we meet them less often than in the past.
In the u s the mean number of close friends dropped from three and 1985 to two
in 2011
most people stumbled into chronic loneliness by accident.
You reach adulthood and become busy with work,
university,
Romance,
kids and Netflix.
There's just not enough time,
the most convenient and easy thing to sacrifice his time with friends.
Did you wake up one day and realize that you feel isolated?
The two yen foot,
close relationships,
but it's hard to find clothes,
connections as adults and so loneliness can become chronic.
While humans feel pretty great about things like iPhones and space ships,
our bodies and minds are fundamentally the same.
The worth 50,000 years ago,
we are still biologically fine tunes to being with each other.
Yeah,
large scale studies have shown that the stress that comes from chronic luminesce
is among the most unhealthy things we can experience as humans.
It makes you age quicker.
It makes cancer deadlier Alzheimer's advanced faster.
Your immune system's weaker.
Loneliness is twice as deadly as obesity and as deadly as smoking a pack of
cigarettes a day.
The most dangerous thing about it is that once it becomes chronic,
it can become self sustaining.
Physical and social pain use common mechanisms in your brain both feel like a
threat and so social pain leads to to and defensive behavior when it's inflicted
on you.
When loneliness becomes chronic,
your brain goes into self preservation load.
It starts to see danger and hostility everywhere,
but that's not all.
Some studies found that when you're lonely,
your brain is much more receptive and alert to social signals.
While at the same time it gets worse at interpreting them correctly.
You pay more attention to others,
but you understand them less.
The part of your brain that recognizes faces gets out of tune and becomes more
likely to categorize neutral faces as hostile,
which makes it distrustful of others.
Loneliness makes you assume the worst about other's intentions towards you.
Because of this perceived hostile world,
you can become a more self centered to protect yourself,
which can make you appear more cold,
unfriendly and socially awkward.
The new radiar
f loneliness has become a strong presence in your life.
The first thing you can do is to try to recognize the vicious cycle you may be
trapped in.
It usually goes something like this.
An initial feeling of isolation leads to feelings of tension and sadness,
which makes you focus your attention selectively on negative interactions with
others.
This makes your thoughts about yourself and others more negative,
which then changes your behavior.
You begin to avoid social interaction,
which leads to more feelings of isolation.
This cycle becomes more severe and harder to escape each time.
Loneliness makes you sit far away from others in class,
not answer the phone.
When friends call decline invitations until the invitation stop.
Each and every one of us has a story about ourselves and if your story becomes
the people exclude you,
others pick up on that and so the outside world can become the way you feel
about it.
This is often a slow creeping process that takes years and can end in depression
and a mental state that prevents connections.
Even if you yearn for them.
The first thing you can do to escape it is to accept that loneliness is a
totally normal feeling and nothing to be ashamed of.
Literally everybody feels lonely at some point in their life.
It's a universal human experience.
You can't eliminate or ignore a feeling until it goes away magically,
but you can accept that you feel it and get rid of.
It's cause you can self examine what you focus your attention on and check if
you are selectively concentrating on negative things.
Was this interaction with a colleague ready negative or was it really neutral or
even positive?
What was the actual content of an interaction?
What did the other person say and did they say something bad or did you add
extra meaning to their words?
Maybe another person was not ready,
reacting negatively,
but just short on time.
Then there are your thoughts about the world.
Are you assuming the worst about other's intentions?
Do you enter a social situation and have already decided how it will go?
Do you assume others don't want you around?
Are you trying to avoid being hurt and not risking opening up,
and if so,
can you try to give others the benefit of the doubt?
Can you just assume that they're not against you?
Can you risk being open and vulnerable again and lastly,
your behavior?
Are you avoiding opportunities to be around others?
Are you looking for excuses to decline invitations or are you pushing others
away preemptively to protect yourself?
Are you acting as if you're getting a tax?
Are you really looking for new connections or have you become complacent with
your situation?
Of course,
every person and situation is unique and different and just introspection alone
might not be enough.
If you feel unable to solve your situation by yourself,
please try to reach out and get professional help.
It's not a sign of weakness but have courage.
However,
we look at loneliness as a purely individual problem that needs solving to
create more personal happiness or as a public health crisis.
It is something that deserves right more attention.
Humans have built a world that's nothing short of amazing,
and yet none of the shiny things we've made is able to satisfy or substitute our
fundamental biological need for connection.
Most animals get what they need from their physical surroundings.
We get what we need from each other and we need to build our artificial human
world.
Based on that.
Let's try something together.
Let's reach out to someone today.
Regardless if you feel a little bit low knee or if you want to make someone
else's day better,
maybe write a friend you haven't spoken to in a while.
Call a family member who's become a strange invite a work buddy for a coffee or
just go to something you're usually too afraid to go to or too lazy to go to
like a d and d event or a sports club.
Everybody's different so you know what's a good fit for you.
Maybe nothing will come of it and that's okay.
Don't do this with any expectations.
The goal is just to open up a base to exercise your connection muscles so they
can grow stronger over time or to help others exercise them.
We want to recommend two of the books we read while researching this video.
Emotional first aid by Guy Wench,
a book that addresses among other topics,
how to deal with loneliness in a way that we found helpful and actionable and
load in s human nature and the need for social connection by John Cacioppo and
William Patrick.
It's an entertaining and scientific exploration as to why we experience
loneliness on a biological level,
how it spread in society,
and what science has to say about how to escape as links for both books and the
video description.